[Musique]
bonjour françois tel t elle bonjour
merci d'être avec nous l'année 2020 sera
celle du sans contact plus de bize plus
d'accolades la crise sanitaire qui
évidemment rend cette distance physique
comme la norme et vous raconter tout
cela dans ce livre chez flammarion la
société du sans contact selphy d'un
monde en chute c'est le titre pour le
sous titre pour le moins pessimiste
d'abord quelle est cette société pour
elle à décrire un peu brièvement et
est-ce qu'elle existait déjà avant la
crise sanitaire oui la crise sanitaire
n'a fait que renforcer en fait cette
société où on est de plus en plus
s'éloigner les uns des autres en fait
pour résumer la distanciation à physique
on a subi aujourd'hui qu'on subit
toujours un peu depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire c'est un peu le modèle
économique finalement dégâts femmes
google apple facebook amazon et
microsoft c'est à dire que si nous
pouvions constamment vivre la vie
derrière un écran ce serait un peu leur
vie rêvée puisque c'est comme ça qu'ils
gagnent de l'argent on rappelle que ces
entreprises fonctionnent sur le temps
d'attention qu'on offre à nos écrans un
temps d'attention qui est donc monétiser
pour qu'une cible publicitaire pour
qu'on soit une cible publicitaire
excepté nous touchent et la crise
sanitaire n'a fait qu'accélérer ce
phénomène les gars femmes comme vous les
appelez ces géants du numérique n'aurait
pas pu imaginer une telle opportunité
économique et les ont pu en rêver ils
ont gagné quoi cinq ou dix ans
exactement leur dirai qu'ils ont gagné
beaucoup d'argent quand on voit les
grands vainqueurs de cette situation il
ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont eu du
mal qui ont toujours du mal aujourd'hui
mais amazon a fait des chiffres records
notamment en capitalisation boursière
pareil pour apple pareil pour netflix
donc les grands gagnants effectivement
ce sont ces entreprises là ça c'est d'un
point de vue économique mais aussi d'un
point de vue philosophique prenons par
exemple le cas de l'enseignement à
distance il y avait encore quelques
bastions se disaient oui mais
l'enseignement c'est quand même dans le
face à face dans du réel c'est en classe
eh bien on a vu avec l'école à la maison
que des grandes entreprises se sont
positionnés sur ce marché-là l'était
déjà mais elles se sont accélérées idem
pour le télétravail c'est à dire
qu'effectivement cette période a permis
à ces entreprises d'accélérer leur
volonté de nous mettre tous à distance
les uns des autres ou plutôt tous
derrière ce fameux écran qui encore une
fois est leur modèle économique pour eux
mais n'est peut-être pas long terme
quelque chose de proche table pour qu'on
puisse continuer à échanger
véritablement est tout simplement dans
notre lien humain site et même un
exemple celui twitter qui envisage de
faire du télétravail à vie avec ses
salariés à vis exactement à vie jack
dorsey donc le patron de twitter a
proposé assez vite d'ailleurs à tous ses
employés qui le désiraient la
possibilité de télétravailler avis alors
faut savoir que les bureaux de twitter
n'ont toujours pas ouvert aujourd'hui
ils imaginent l'ouvrir peut-être en
avril printemps 21 2021 sait même pas
dit que sa ré ouvre à ce moment là mais
en tout cas la philosophie vous la
comprenez le télétravail avis facebook
par ailleurs imaginer que 50% de ses
employés dans le monde passerait en
télétravail un télétravail permanent
c'est là où je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est qu'on a tous
dû faire du télétravail est un peu par
nécessité mais ces entreprises l'install
comme une norme mais c'est quoi le
télétravail quand on réfléchit c'est des
individus qui travaillent seuls chez eux
face à un écran qui sont plus dans la
sociabilité qui sont plus dans le
partage qui sont plus aussi dans la
découverte d'une idée comme ça qui se
fait au milieu d'un couloir dans une
rencontre impromptue de service qui se
rend compte hop tiens on pense à quelque
chose c'est aussi une force syndicale
entre guillemets qui meurt c'est à dire
qu'on peut plus se dire quelles sont nos
conditions de travail comment on
pourrait s'unir etc et enfin c'est la
chaise vide c'est à dire que avant quand
une personne n'était pas là au bureau on
l'a remarqué en s'inquiéter pour elle
est ce qu'elle est malade est ce qu'elle
va bien aujourd'hui il ya plus de
chaises donc on ne voit même plus la
personne qui n'est pas là on la voit
plus en train de souffrir et le jour où
elle se fait licencier potentiellement
on n'est même plus là pour la pleurer
dernière petite anecdote hubert à
licencier plus de 3000 personnes à
distance par visioconférence pendant ce
confinement sert 3000 personnes 3000
employés un d'hubert c'était des gens
qui étaient employés administratifs ont
été licenciés en quatre minutes derrière
une dent qui a une très grande violence
aussi dans cette société hyper connectés
sans contact est une expression d'une
sociologue que vous citez dans votre
livre c'est sherry turkle sociologue
américaine qui dit que nous ne sommes
finalement plus que seul ensemble oui
exactement ce l'ensemble c'est une
magnifique expression est on
si elle est si bonne c'est parce qu'on
la visualise assez bien ça qu'on imagine
effectivement cette cohorte d'individus
qu'on est tous devenus connectés à leur
attention les nouvelles technologies
peuvent être très utiles on utilise tous
dans notre travail dans notre quotidien
dans le confinement s'affermissent a
permis d'aborder les allemands
effectivement ça a permis de sortir de
l'isolément mais le seul ensemble cette
idée qu'on a beau être les uns à côté
des autres lorsqu'on est plongé dans
notre écran plonger dans ce miroir qui
parfois réconfortant parce qu'ils nous
ressemblent parce que c'est un miroir
facile qu'un échappatoire qui qui nous
permet finalement de tuer l'ennui eh
bien on n'est pas avec les autres on a
l'impression d'être avec l'autre parce
qu'en fait à côté on a l'impression
d'être avec les autres parce qu'on peut
communiquer avec les autres mais en fait
on est seul ensemble donc on a beaucoup
à perdre 100 sans le contact physique m
l'autre à distance c'est aussi s'en
méfier est ce qu'elle vous fait peur
vous françois saltiel cette société la
selle ou à même se séduire à distance
oui c'est ça vous savez il ya quelque
chose qui team qui me terrifie encore un
peu en ce moment c'est le fait qu'on
trouve plus dans la capacité de se
serrer la main par exemple avance serrer
la main c'était un acte quand même
pacifique ça voulait dire je n'ai pas
d'armes tu n'as pas d'armes via on se
serre la main aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire se serrer la main peut-être
presque un acte si on pousse un peu
mortel c'est à dire je peux te
transmettre le virus qui va peut-être
ramener vers la fin alors ça c'est très
contextuel c'est lié à la situation
sanitaire mais oui ça fait peur de plus
avoir cette capacité à penser contre soi
même vous savez quand on est beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux on a beaucoup
parlé des effets bulle des effets filtre
c'est soit on est face à des gens qui
pensent la même chose que nous donc ça
nous radicalise ça a été beaucoup
d'études ont été faites là dessus sur la
manière dont tombe à avoir une pensée
encore plus extrême et d'ailleurs ça a
été utilisé dans de nombreux cas
notamment lors des élections
présidentielles américaines c'est à dire
qu'on va se radicaliser sur un propos
soient y aurait une polarité tel qui a
put vraiment des changes possible
regarder un réseau comme twitter c'est
très compliqué d'avoir une conversation
comme on a en ce moment dans du temps
long c'est à dire que tout de suite
c'est des clash donc soit on est dedans
face à un miroir qui nous ressemble qui
nous réconforte soit on est face à
quelque chose qui nous oppose et dont on
a tendance à se dire à 100 à se
distancier soit en souffrir donc où l
échange ou et la discussion et la
lettonie la rencontre où l altérité
alors mettre l'autre à distance c'est
parfois aussi le remplacer vous en
parler c'est l'étape suit vente avec
l'arrivée de toutes ces machines parlant
ces machines conversationnel qui ont
souvent des noms de femmes comme alexa
par exemple pour en citer une qui elle
remplace ces machines remplacent le vide
en fait elles sont c'est un palliatif à
notre solitude moderne ça touche à la
fois les célibataires par exemple qui
comme dans certains pays au japon
tendance vraiment avoir de plus en plus
recours à ces machines conversationnel
c'est le cas des poupées sexuelle mais
ce n'est pas juste l'image qu'on en a
c'est à dire une poupée en latex non
c'est une compagne c'est un compagnon
c'est un partenaire de vie c'est
quelqu'un qui est dans notre quotidien
qui nous parlent qu'ils nous répondent
qui apprend de nous grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle et qui
surtout composent cette solitude
terrifiante mais ça va du célibataire
aulas personnes âgées en fin de vie qui
est dans un ehpad dont les proches peu
importe donné par les proches et qui va
converser avec ses assistants et qui
avoir l'impression de parler un humain
un humain parce que finalement toutes
ces machines sont d' un
anthropomorphisme très élaborés c'est à
dire qu'on a l'impression parler à un
humain du moins une machine qui ressent
des émotions et vous expliquer bien que
finalement jamais ou très rarement ont
presque jamais on peut le dire dans
l'histoire un tel pouvoir celui des gars
femme a été détenu par un si petit
nombre de personnes
ce danger là c'est l'absence de
démocratisation d'un tel pouvoir il peut
nous mener où tous ces gens tous ces
architectes la silicon valley malgré une
concurrence de façade sont très proches
c'est à dire mark zuckerberg donc
facebook jeff deux os du côté d'amazon
peter thil qui en est l'actionnaire de
paypal et qui a été un des premiers
actionnaires de facebook également et
bien tous ces personnes là sont tous des
hommes de la toux des hommes blancs et
tous des hommes blancs à tendance
transhumanistes à dire qu'ils sont en
quête d'immortalité et d'une philosophie
libertarienne ce que l'on entend par une
philosophie libertarienne c'est la
volonté de vouloir un peu est limité
éliminé par dont l'état protecteur donc
c'est pas seulement un projet économique
c'est un projet politique c'est un
projet politique c'est un projet
philosophique c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
si vous analysez un peu la situation
tous ces hommes là sont en train
d'imaginer aussi notre société ailleurs
où l'individu et roy au delà des états
exactement alors certains l'imaginent
sur des îles flottantes
c'est le cas de peter steele et patrie
friedman d'autres vont l'imaginer dans
des quartiers préempter des villes comme
google qui est en train d'en cesser
google city c'était le cas notamment à
toronto le projet qui a été abandonné à
cause du colonel virus mais qui restent
encore dans les plans de google un mot
sur les google christie's ce n'est pas
juste une ville comme ça hyper connecté
à l'est elle est hyper connecté le
foncier appartient à google et google
demande juste d'être dans une zone un
peu des taxes et pour pouvoir offrir
tous ses biens publics mais c'est aussi
une manière de présenter en fait
l'espace public le plus ironique dans
tout ça c'est que les principaux
dirigeants de la silicon valley mettent
leurs enfants dans des écoles sans aucun
écran ça veut dire quoi ça signifie quoi
ça veut dire que ce qu'ils veulent pour
les autres ils ne le veulent pas pour
eux-mêmes alors ça qu'on a vu deux
phénomènes par rapport aux enfants des
géants de la silicon valley il ya
effectivement une école qui est
totalement déconnecté alors il ya
beaucoup il ya tous les enfants de la
tête qui sont là bas mais il ya aussi
des enfants parce que ça c'est un petit
peu un pain un peu un mirage médiatique
cette école là elle existe mais surtout
on apprend à ces enfants là à coder donc
soit on les met à distance des outils en
disant je sais que ça peut être
dangereux donc j'ai pas envie que tu
tombes de temps parce qu'il ya vraiment
une charge addictives ans et une
dépendance quand même aux écrans qui ne
vaut pas que du bien soit au contraire
on apprend à les dompter en leur disant
maintien apprend à coder apprend à
construire un robot justement comment on
résiste comment on fait pour sauvegarder
nos libertés dans ce monde là totalement
numérisée déjà il faut en avoir
conscience pour la première étape c'est
la prise de conscience ça c'est un
premier temps ensuite faut pas qu'on
soit vu dans une lucidité stérile faut
qu'on arrive à reconquérir notre liberté
d'attention donc se dire voilà j'ai pris
conscience de la dangerosité de ces
produits moi mon petit niveau j'essaye
de les mettre à distance pour pouvoir
regagner un peu de mon attention mais
aussi les premiers à ce monde d'après ou
pourrait retrouver par exemple quand les
cafés seront tous très ouvert la
rencontre fortuite
d'une jeune femme d'un jeune homme la
coïncidence ça va arriver moi j'y crois
parce que je vois bien parme sur les
applications de rencontre pour avoir
beaucoup fait d'entretiens avec les gens
qu'ils utilisent une phase de
désenchantement dire que nora premier
temps c'est magnifique on a l'impression
que on peut avoir une multiplicité des
possibles autour de soi il ya ça flatte
l'ego aussi parce complet on arrive à
plaire et puis très vite on est un peu
désenchanté parce qu'on se rend compte
que c'est que ces relations là elles
sont assez éphémère on est toujours dans
un système de comparaison des ans lui il
est peut-être mieux que celle d'hier
enfin audika sera moins bien que celles
de demain donc on est dans une sorte
d'insatisfaction on se rend compte quand
on analyse ses algorithmes qu'on
rencontre pas qui on veut on rencontre
des gens qui sont sélectionnés par un
algorithme qui par nature est étriqué et
nous fait rencontrer les gens qu'on va
avoir beaucoup de jeunesse qu'on veut
confier son destin amoureux de la
rencontre à une machine à une entreprise
je suis pas sûr quand on a conscience de
ça c'est déjà différent alors après oui
moi je crois encore et encore plus que
jamais même au circuit court de la
sociabilité je crois que les gens avec
ce qu'ils sont en train de vivre
aujourd'hui ils vont avoir un désir un
besoin d'aller se rencontrer de nouveau
alors peut-être une dernière question
sur les politiques classiques j'entends
les élus les gouvernements est-ce qu'ils
favorisent cette société du sans contact
ou est ce qu'ils permettent une
alternative alors sur la question
politique il ya déjà un problème c'est
en parlant france parle sur nos 577
députés à l'assemblée nationale ils sont
assez peu nombreux à savoir et à
connaître en fait ces enjeux la soirée
par les autres sont largués ils sont
déconnectés parce que vous avez vu c'est
un travail déjà d'arriver à comprendre
comment ces outils fonctionnent c'est
pas leur génération et c'est vrai qu'ils
n'ont pas totalement la conscience de
cet enjeu là où ceux qui l'ont sont
plutôt minoritaire deuxième chose il
faudrait effectivement avoir une volonté
politique internationale et là il ya une
possibilité qui serait celle du
démantèlement qui a été porté d'ailleurs
par de nombreux candidats démocrates aux
états unis le démantèlement ça veut dire
qu'on prend conscience qu'une entreprise
comme google aujourd'hui un pouvoir
démesuré qu'on l'a laissé faire et qu'il
faut revenir un peu une politique anti
trust qui avait eu lieu dans les eaux
aux etats-unis dans quelles régulations
l'arrêt convertir par les américains eux
mêmes en tout cas c'est quand vous
regardez bien tout les gars femmes sont
tous des entreprises américaines donc
certes ya la concurrence chinoise qui
arrive on voit bien que derrière la
guerre qui oppose tik tok avec donald
trump est une guerre numérique entre la
puissance américaine la puissance
chinoise émergentes mais quand même 80%
des plates formes qu'on utilise son
american donc le pouvoir est là bas et
il ya quand même un mouvement là bas de
résistance et je pense qu'effectivement
se dire on a laissé un monstre se
construit un monstre de données qui
n'est pas capable de se réguler parce
qu'en fait c'est pas son objectif c'est
pas son besoin son besoin c'est de
continuer à se développer et c'est
peut-être permettre effectivement une
régulation et là un peu l'antithèse du
la philosophie libertarienne nantes on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
revenir un peu un état régulateur 1
étape providence pour essayer de
protéger finalement ces citoyens qui ne
doit pas être juste des utilisateurs ou
les usagers merci beaucoup françois fall
thiel merci beaucoup à vous
[Musique]